tout à l'heure à la tribune de
l'assemblée le ministre de la santé de
la famille madame simone veil annoncé
qu'il n'y aurait pas de hausse du taux
de cotisations sur les salaires pendant
encore deux ans et elle s'est donné
trois priorités maîtriser les dépenses
de santé
favoriser la famille assumer la
solidarité en faveur des personnes âgées
et pour madame belle il s'agit
maintenant de s'occuper d'abord des
[ __ ] des améliorations considérables
ont été apportées au cours des années
récentes à notre système de sécurité
sociale et pour la plupart les français
bénéficient aujourd'hui d'une protection
efficace mais il reste néanmoins pour
les plus défavorisés des progrès
accomplis
je pense ici à toutes celles et ceux
vers invalides accidenté qui sont les
plus exposés aux risques sociaux mais
aussi les moins bien vers car privé d'un
revenu professionnel permanent
c'est à mon sens vers eux que doit
maintenant se porter notre attention